una parálisis poco habitual en Hollywood
tras no llegar a un acuerdo con la
alianza de productores de cine y
televisión alrededor de 11.500
guionistas de cine y televisión entraron
en huelga por primera vez en 15 años la
llegada de las plataformas de streaming
cambió las reglas de juego
escribí la guerra de los mundos ya sabes
la película de Steven spielberg con esa
película gané mucho dinero en ventas al
extranjero en dvd cuando se emitió por
cable Pues bien Ahora una película como
esa iría a Disney Plus donde pagarán ya
sabes centavos por dólar de lo que
solían tener que pagar en un entorno
competitivo y tus residuales se calculan
de esa manera entre las peticiones está
un reconocimiento justo por los llamados
residuales es decir las remuneraciones
que se reciben por la retransmisión de
sus proyectos Pero además los creadores
se enfrentan ahora a un nuevo reto la
erupción de la inteligencia artificial
el temor es Union en France 24 el
guionista Moisés Zamora estamos muy
preocupados porque pueden utilizar este
este el chat gpt como manera de
reescribir guiones a contar nuevas
historias de algo reemplazar todo el
sistema que para nosotros es esencial
para poder tener una carrera profesional
como guionista en Hollywood la última
huelga de guionistas ocurrió entre 2007
y 2008 y duró 100 días había costado
unos 2100 millones de dólares a la
economía de California ahora con esta
huelga indefinida el impacto en las
producciones será gradual siendo los
programas nocturnos de toxo que se
escriben y emiten diariamente los
inmediatamente afec